hello welcome to the lobby game spots
weekly hangout every tuesday at 2 p.m
pacific right here on videogames.com hi
i'm danny dwyer joined by mike mccarty
and peter brown gentlemen how you doing
great how are video games great
yeah really good do you have any time to
do anything else in your life except
play video games this weekend
uh i make my own soap you made your own
soap
no i thought we were joking
wait did you actually make your own
stuff no i buy mine is that a fight club
reference
oh yeah with lie and then the kisses
hand wait it wasn't the fight club
reference no it's just that's what came
out of your mouth that's what i was
thinking about i made my own soap i
realized you're asking me a question
then kind of just train a thought leapt
out of my mouth that's what it was yep
wow your psychologist probably has a
great laugh yeah yeah rorschach peter
bryan psychologist
what do you what are you playing this
weekend uh i'm about to start playing
afro samurai 2 oh wow which came out
today um i didn't know was coming out
today no no one told me
because he's samurai he's like in the
shadows and he's like bam release date
no well apparently you're not playing as
the afro samurai himself you should have
called it something else then well i
think it's in the subtitle all right
don't worry about it it's called afraid
samurai 2 the other guy kuma's revenge i
think okay that might be do you play as
akuma you play as kuma kuma akuma from a
popular fighting game no no all right
that's a shame
right well i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
buy our first time right today are you
uh are you reviewing it yeah that's what
i'm gonna play okay cool you still
haven't played the witcher yet though
no
give me time
all right good night everybody
uh i want to talk
somebody else's ghost i wonder if i
can't wonder if that came across on
video that was terrifying chelsea's
heard something really funny uh i want
to talk to you about all the games
you've played because there's still a
bunch of big games coming out in 2016.
you think it's over hasn't even started
yet peter brown your reviews editor so
you're all too aware of what's coming up
over the next two months but just in
case you weren't i prepared a fancy list
of some of the games that we should get
excited about how about all the games we
should get excited um
there's probably some people who are
excited about wwe 2k16 which is not on
this list so i don't want to say it's a
perfect list but it's a list of some of
the biggest shall we say games coming
out over the next two months starting
this week actually i'm not even sure if
this counts i'm not sure this might be
in that category tony hawk pro skater 5
is out
this friday said this week not true it's
not you're using outdated information
it's at when's it at the 29th 29th
you're seeing the 25th yeah
it got pushed back i don't know but
randy was talking to me the other day
and he had the 25th all i know is it's
coming out the 29th okay cool so next
week excited about that at all i'm
interested to see how
what they're going to do like if they're
gonna try to mimic the old style of
gameplay completely uh or introduce like
new you know aspects to the game uh
that's going to really determine how i
feel about it because i can go back and
play old tony hawk games right so if
they really want to get me excited
they've got to do something with it but
i would like a little bit of that
classic flair it's itching by the
trailers it looks like they're very much
leaning into the multiplayer sort of
party mode create parks and then share
them with your buddies kind of aspect of
it so be interesting to see how much
they lean into that but then i guess the
first sort of real big box game coming
out who would have thunk it the first of
two uh
um music playing games yeah back of the
band rock band 4 at october 6. mike you
excited about that yeah i haven't played
rock band since
three was that the last one college for
me was very recently so that would have
been like four months ago yeah okay yeah
two weeks ago i have class in like 10
minutes so let's hurry up um yeah i'm
excited about this i played both this
and guitar hero live at like preview
events and whatnot um rock band's kind
of new twist they're putting the
gameplay is like the rpg progression in
um the career mode which seems
interesting enough to i mean i'm just
excited for these instrument based
rhythm games to come back just to have
an excuse to play them again yeah dust
off the old drums of course they've done
a really good job i think of making sure
that like old dlc and old peripherals
work generally across the board for this
that brings me to my question though for
both of you guys like we may be excited
for this game but are you excited to
have a bunch of plastic instruments
around your house again like the guitars
are pretty innocuous like you can kind
of you know you can store them away
relatively easy there's the drums that
are a problem and i've moved into a
place that i'm on like a second level so
that somebody's sleeping underneath
you're going to make friends real quick
i know that's like a massive problem
because iced always like having a couple
of drinks and even just kind of larping
on the drums for a while it probably
won't go down i have to put like a lot
of mats underneath them again yeah and
of course yeah as you said guitar hero
live coming out at just two weeks later
on october 20th any preference peter
between the two of them i'm not really
big into these particular music games
mostly because i suck at them
usually i don't like games i suck at but
i think they're great and i'm actually i
really like people who do enjoy these
games like play them because they get
really into it yeah so sort of by proxy
i enjoy it um but you know i kind of i
could give echo either way cool folks in
the chat in the comments let us know
which one of those you're
most interested in uh hd collections of
course have been a big thing this year
again uncharted the nathan drake
collection coming out october 9th and
not too far away you excited about that
one mike yeah i'm more excited i haven't
played the first one since
i get released i forget what year that
was but i mean i played two and
everybody says two's the best but i was
always one of those weird people who
enjoyed three more so i want to go back
and see if i was just
drunk or like just
being stupid you were drunk well
actually no i would have been like
again i don't know how old that was when
it was came out but yeah i always really
enjoyed three but two i think i didn't
play through in one sitting
so i want to go back and see if it
really is just as good as everyone says
because again i haven't seen it
firsthand in a long time but i'm sure
this is a good primer for um you know
when four comes out yeah that's the way
i feel it's a good way to get ready
again not too many not too many excuses
for ps4 as well coming up for the rest
of the year so that's right at least one
you can you can get if you're a
playstation owner um next stock uh
october 23rd it's that time of year
again time to play a new assassin's
creed game uh syndicus i played it at an
event a couple of months ago and i was
actually sort of surprisingly
entertained by the sort of the sandbox
nature of some of those levels they've
done and like the different sort of ways
in which you can tackle them sort of in
that like fun emerging way that like
metal gear solid the way you've got a
base and you can sort of attacked it in
any way you want felt like assassin's
creed games were very rigid for a long
long time super super boring and like
just too many missions that were tedious
um but yeah after playing that i felt a
little bit better about it have either
of you played any syndicate over the
past couple of months no but you've got
me interested now actually because the
things you're mentioning are gone are
problems ahead of this series which is
kind of why i left it behind yeah on a
problem they had with watchdogs as well
and like i've
like been very vocal about how irritated
i've been with assassin's creed for a
couple of years so i'm kind of like i'm
really cautious optimistic to see uh
what our reviewer thinks about it when
it comes along mike you've played it at
all over the past couple of months yeah
about a month ago i played as evie uh so
this is the first time that a woman is
one of the leading characters and you
know first on a console personality
personal console correct uh
assassin's creed liberation on also head
um for her name but yeah it's it was
she supposedly to be more stealth-minded
of the two you can see jacob's kind of
just
mowing jack and fools yeah and i think
he's getting the majority of the story
missions but if you just want to explore
you can be eevee as much as you can
which will be cool because i've always
kind of when you have the choice i've
always gravitated towards stealth
and you know metal gear solid five i've
been doing the same thing and dishonored
and i did the same thing so i'd like to
see if that carries over well and makes
syndicate interesting enough for me to
get back into because
uh black flag i really liked but i
haven't been that interested in the
franchise for a long time and i it's
it's too bad because i really liked it
for the first
five countries yeah that's the problem
they sort of had was almost the problem
that happened with tomb raider where
eventually whoever got in control of the
game or got like mainstream and then
they just turned it into an action game
when it was never an action game to
begin with like assassin's creed used to
be about spending a lot of time about
killing one person and then suddenly you
were just mowing down dozens and dozens
of folks and on that same day the legend
of zelda triforce heroes coming out on
that hot nintendo wii u peter you
excited about that i am excited like
zelda is a series that just sort of
warms my heart for the most part you
know i've liked pretty much every game
in the series
and this one sort of falls into the same
camp as four swords uh so i'm i played a
little bit of e3 i enjoyed the aspect of
you know you're putting on different
outfits it changes your character and
changes your abilities and the interplay
within a team dynamic uh seems fun and
interesting it's not a mainline zelda
game but that's okay cool something for
the wii u as well for owners of that
because unfortunately of course we've
had a delay for uh star fox as well uh i
think you mean something for the 3ds oh
sorry 3ds all right is there anything
else
is great
buy one this holiday i don't know um
ww2k16 as i said is coming out october
25th only two days after those games but
that's also the same day that halo 5
guardians comes out mike you excited
about that you're a big halo fan yeah i
am uh this is actually the more excited
i've been for a halo
in a while i said well there haven't
been that many halos but four came out
with 2012 you know it's been a couple of
years yeah i mean the master chief
collection as a game is great obviously
did not have a great launch but now that
it's all for the most part set i really
enjoyed playing through all those i did
those recently and then i did spartan
ops that co-op mode in halo 4 that
bridges the campaigns between four and
five story-wise um i just played halo 5
campaign at a recent event i can't talk
about it yet but i will have a preview
up tomorrow morning cool about the
campaign you get to play as fire team
osiris which is uh sergeant jameson
locke he's
chasing down the master chief and blue
team if you're into halo lore they are
fred kelly and
linda you know way more about this than
i was assuming no yeah no i should i've
read a lot of the books and i don't know
why you don't usually get into laura i
just think it's pretty interesting
sci-fi a lot of times a lot of the
novels and whatnot but
essentially it's you know the first game
you're playing the very first halo you
think you're one of the last you're the
last spartan but it turns out you're not
a bunch survived reach this from halo
reach the battle and it's really
interesting because
you play as um
four different spartans on both teams
and you're kind of chasing down the
chief and it's calling into question
whether he's really a good person and a
hero okay which is interesting to me
because he's always been painted as this
you know he's bombastic and he's bold
and everything and he's always just
blowing up
ships in outer space but
he's kind of been boring up until halo
4. um him and his relationship maybe
he's a tool of an evil
yeah and then there's something
cipher yes
halo 5 guardians comes out on the 25th
and
one thing i want to ask both of you guys
november 3rd
do either of you have the need
peter do you have the need uh
i like racing games like i'm a casual
racing game man what
what do you think i'm talking about here
you need for speed yeah i need to come
back
you got the need mike
i mean don't think so do the need
no subtitle i'll check it out need for
speed just need for speed we're
resetting this game franchise
peter's excited about it he's got the
need
i'm interested i'm curious to see what
they're going to do like
that series began a long time ago on pc
and i loved it and over the years i've
just become so jaded with what they've
been doing like i love the hot pursuit
stuff that was fun
since then i just like i don't really
see where it fits in like
the you know like the landscape of
racing games like why do i really want
to play this over you know like say the
crew which i didn't love but i still
enjoyed um the forza uh
yeah i mean that looks wonderful like
gran turismo i actually really like gran
turismo i know it's got a lot of
problems but there's something about
those problems that are endearing to me
um so i just don't yeah
we'll see i'm curious like i'm probably
going to play a little bit of it this
has the full motion videos right yeah
that stuff's pretty cool the guy from
this is a movie a lot of people probably
have not seen go for it uh green street
hooligans nope made up oh yeah soccer
first yeah it's it's the west versus
milwaukee yeah and uh there's a guy in
it his name is bauer i think and he's in
jefferson
jack bauer and then he voices
a snake yeah
who also is going to be in the full
motion videos for nephi no i'm just
kidding
well i moved when i moved to london uh i
was living there three days and i was
overlooking the west ham it was like
about half a mile away the stadium and
there was a fire and it was because
middle wall fans had set a car on fire
yeah pretty good so that's a need for
speed actually the one thing i like
about naval speed or the one thing
that's really interesting in me is the
entire game gets uh played over the
course of one night
yeah all those fmvs happen in one night
that's right yeah endless light in this
game no daylight yep i remember hearing
that and thinking what yeah we were
getting come when you talk about it blew
my mind
i'm really into it um a couple of days
after that november 6th call of duty
time black ops 3 uh call of duty fans
either of you i like the campaigns i
think they're fun are you excited for
blackboard multiplayer a little bit yeah
not dying for it but i'll give it a shot
yeah the treyarch campaigns always kind
of deliver as far as the first black ops
was pretty refreshing it was yeah
definitely that psychological stuff and
then the jfk conspiracy theories and
we played a lot of black ops 3 the beta
on ps4 and xbox one um you know eric tay
and chris waters had gotten a lot into
it rob hanlery had perfected that glitch
ability because you know the multiplayer
they have those um
the specialist classes now that can you
can kind of do these super abilities
like you might in destiny yeah they're
doing an overwatch or a or right or in
every fps coming out next year yeah
battleborn yeah
wow that's the way of things that'll cry
so excited about the multiplayer peter
you're excited about the single-player
stuff yeah yeah looks like a strong
enough package i guess we'll know soon
enough for call of duty fans november
6 that comes out four days before maybe
the biggest day
of the video game year
so many games coming out that one day
so many games coming out that one day
but the one everyone wants to talk about
right off the bat uh rodeo the sky
ranger coming out for wii u in 3ds yuji
naka is a genius
finally making its way to north america
you know what's crazy is the wii u
version of that game comes packaged with
a wii version of the game that isn't a
port it's a totally different
reimagining of the game what yeah it's
like two games in one he's reimagining a
game that just released the same well no
the wii one was finished like a long
time ago and then they came back and
they finished the wii u version after
it's not just like upgraded visuals like
they've changed certain aspects of the
gameplay and like
i know i didn't expect you to notice
much about radea
this is peter number two
get your get your pre-orders in make
sure that november 10th you're not the
one waiting in line
do you have it do you have our debt now
we're sold there damn it if that does
happen there are a couple other games
coming out that day uh fallout 4 rise of
the tomb raider and starcraft 2 legacy
to void never heard of it let's start
with fallout 4 first of all my goodness
if i wasn't working in video games i'd
be taking a month off this is like this
is going to be so much fun peter are you
excited for for the the fourth one okay
i am i am it's been a long time since i
played fallout 3 but i really like that
and i'm really excited to see that some
of the uh the id soft guys have
contributed to the shooting aspect of
this game which we all know now is like
way better than three the vat system is
no longer a crutch for that broken uh
shooty shooty bang bang stuff so
uh no yeah i'm really excited and as
someone who really enjoyed metal gear
and the way that it's open world
functioned i know it's very different
from the way fallout 4's works but i'm
very curious to uh to see
how it impresses me because i'm sure it
will and i'm sure that'll also change
you know my opinion a bit on what was
great or maybe not so great about metal
gear and that's always really fun i
think is having your your thoughts and
opinions challenged and learning new
stuff and i think fallout 4 is a great
opportunity for all of that yeah i've
given back into fallout 3 and i was
doing a bunch of like stuff i hadn't
done before like creating new weapons
and you know like using the the the you
know the whatever the sheets of
schematics you get and then i was
looking back at the trailers for fallout
4 and like you can build your own
weapons out of like anything you want
like there's going to be so much depth
to this um really exciting and it's been
five years since new vegas so you know
that's a lot of uh it's gonna feel like
a much more different uh fallout game
hopefully yeah uh mike uh what you uh
take either one of these tomb raider or
starcraft which one would you like damn
it uh i really
i'm a big starcraft fan so i'm looking
forward to that but i think that's one
of those games i'll be playing
throughout
the next year right okay
and uh right as a tomb raider i'm really
excited for it doesn't
fall as high on my priority list as
fallout 4 but
um both starcraft and ryzen tomb raider
both look great um rise of the tomb
raider i'm excited to see
where they take lara now because
obviously
the first tomb raider reboot 2013 was
awesome i liked it a lot uh and i think
they did a great job of characterizing
her as more than just this acting hero
my worry is that the trailer the
gameplay trailer they put out shows her
again just like straight up murdering
dozens of people which just seems like
like as fun as the last tomb raider was
it just like i played that game trying
not to kill people because it just
seemed like a kind of too easy and b
just not in the spirit of tomb raider
like it didn't feel like like she's just
ridiculously op for some you know
nightmaring armor you know it's kind of
crazy at some stages and also in
the last tomb raider it was just these
it's like a band of
pirates from what i remember but now
these guys look like some yeah
military forces yeah mercenaries so i
guess we'll find out uh yeah looking
forward to that of course coming out and
all that xbox one exclusivity nonsense
on november 10th uh starcraft 2 as well
interesting to think that this is the i
guess the third this is the end of their
trilogy which started again five years
ago and it's crazy to think that uh like
the starcraft 2 community is a
completely different beast to what it
was five years ago it's what it was four
years ago like even two years ago like
at this stage it's almost like they're
releasing a game
for a community that's moved on to
different competitive games and you know
like i'm mostly looking forward to
playing it so i can enjoy the single
player stuff but um yeah it's going to
be reducing to see what the reception is
for that of course that's coming out
around the time of blizzcon as well so
maybe uh maybe there'll be a bit more
excitement around it come november time
and november 26th
we're not done yet trackmania turbo is
coming out woo yeah any chuck mania fans
here no
not really it's a
i played it on vr did you do the vr
thing
why would i it's like the one game you
should never play in vr exactly it's
like oh my god this is amazing but it's
impossible to turn you've it's like a
it's like a discipline and you know vr
is like you put on the headset and it's
all about like moving around the space
and moving your head never done it
trackmania is like
a discipline in keeping your head as
like tight as possible because you're
like driving into corners and it's all
about like these little twitch driving
controls so if you turn a little bit
like you're done in dustin it's just one
of those experiences is not meant for vr
no and i don't understand why people try
to shoehorn it in there because it's
dumb in case they need a crow effect
case need a crutch
no no it's a great game i love track
manual cool no i look forward to talking
very well could be a great game but vr
for that no maybe not we'll see maybe if
hey if that's what morpheus ends up
being just a weird like additive modes
to other games then i'm i'm not so sure
but i love it aesthetic looks cool
there's this crazy double driver mode
where both of you are driving the car at
the same time it's like driver's ed yeah
yeah basically except both of you are
driving not one of you at a time uh
which is pretty good look no wait you
didn't have the the person in the car
that had like the brakes they could
apply at any moment dude i drove in
ireland for like two years at a real
license it's a whole different world
don't don't even worry about it november
26th for trackmania turbo uh december
1st two more bangers coming out let's
start first of all with the other a
little bit the other avalanche open
world game just cause three uh you
weren't a massive fan of mad max
decent enough game more excited for just
cause three yeah like i think there was
a few things in mad max that were
wonderful
just didn't capitalize on those
what i've played up just cause the
things that are really great are the
things you're doing moment to moment all
the time like moving blowing stuff up uh
getting from one spot to another like
gliding through the air like all of
those feel really good and i really
liked all of that so i'm much more
optimistic for this
um and mad max doesn't look you're
standing underneath the helicopter yeah
what like magnet boots mad max hasn't
you know dis dissuaded me from avalanche
as a whole it was made by a different
team like countries apart anyway but
yeah this game just looks
fantastic so i mean we'll see yeah
looking forward to it hitting december
first the same day as rainbow six siege
uh we played a lot of us here in the
office i'm sure there's a bunch of stuff
coming up this week i think about
rainbow six siege as well um i'm not
sure how much we talk about so i'm not
gonna talk about any of it but come back
to gamespot.com for that uh are you guys
excited about it at all it seems like
sort of the hype arandus has sort of
waned off a little bit because they're
beating so many betas i just feel like
they've been making like spin-offs to
rainbow six forever when are they gonna
come out with rainbow seven
god
the door's
that way oh you're making my puns look
good
i want ding chavez back you can't have a
rainbow six game without some hot dinghy
toenail maldini he was my number two oh
really no one knows who he is but
antonio maldini he was also in greece
yeah he was a italian i think
well the name
i hope so yeah or is it impossible he
was the uh
explosive specialist i think from
rainbow six
rogue spear which is the first one i
ever played that was great then i've
gone into him yeah rogue spear was a
game that uh
successfully anticipated an actual war
the russian invasion of georgia oh yeah
that literally happened four years later
there's a level when you're like into
blitzy like shooting tanks and then
there was like footage of happening a
couple of years later that tom clancy
yeah cause the internet nancy clancy the
intro to rogue spear was an actual they
were trying to do one of those news
montages yes and it was
startlingly realistic for someone like
of my age yeah or art when we were first
i got it for christmas one year yeah
yeah and then all that stuff started
happening yeah
it's like all this [ __ ] because the
dudes fall real realistically and stuff
it's like watching black mirror and then
and then the prime minister puts his
gentleman's junk in a pig's mouth
um anyway none of that is in rainbow six
siege but uh that's coming out december
1st if you're interested uh and then the
last game is coming out this year
what a year 2015 for video games let's
finish it off with just a cherry on top
the us release of devil's third coming
december 11th you had to go with that
wii u game
what about xenoblade chronicles x yeah i
guess that's coming at you oh you peen
xenoblade chronicles grace devil's third
though
hot
three out of ten to be given three out
of ten three out of ten released in
europe look at this look at that
whoa we just disappeared uh european
players have been quote unquote enjoying
this for the past uh six months or so in
japan as well of course uh but yeah the
us release coming december 11th so make
sure you save all those
game stop vouchers you get for christmas
so you can pick this bad boy up uh in
the new year and that's all the games
coming out uh before we finish mike
mccarty pick one favorite game most
anticipated game coming out between now
and jesus time 2015. fallout 4. all
right peter brown
followed four that's a three i hate to
believe it's kind of a time between fall
and zoom league chronicles like yeah and
devil starts one i know what i'm getting
myself into the other one i'm like what
is inside of this a massive game so
we'll see which one are we talking about
you don't know but also close second is
bloodborne's expansion oh yeah and i'm
curious about battlefront just because i
have some
i'm curious to see how it's going to
turn out because i've been hearing good
things i've been hearing
things that make me hesitate but we'll
see yeah bunch of great games coming out
this year uh many we talked about now
many we didn't so let us know in the
comments what your favorite game is
coming out between now and december 31st
and also what you think is going to be
game of the year 2015 because it is a
absolutely crazy year for video games oh
yeah rocket league
yeah who knows we'll see about that let
us know in the comments all right we're
gonna be back in a second we've got to
talk about konami in a little bit uh
we've also got an exclusive trailer for
guild wars coming up i'm going to ask
mike about his review of a destiny to
take king but first of all here's a
trailer for some hot new batman arkham
knight dlc let's check it out
peggy 18.
oh
so
you were doing so well
snap cat ladies going to be in there
no the camera didn't see you whipping
you're nuts that's pretty good though
congratulations every week here on the
lobby we spend a lot of time on a
tuesday morning in a meeting deciding
what trailers to play uh in between the
various segments this we got a great one
coming up actually right after this bit
which you stick around for which is a
trailer for uh the new guild wars 2
expansion um but uh we only had one
extra slot to pick this week and we went
with batman arkham knight but there was
another one uh which which we didn't
play which was for uh dragon age
inquisition uh but we were looking at it
it was just sort of a toss up
but the reason we ended up not going for
it is because as you will see in a
second um they it starts off with a kind
of a sting saying these are the game of
the year 2014 like various awards it
gets right check this out right first
one up
ign then we've got gameguru.org it's
pronounced guru 3d juegos and then we
just got past it we'll get it we'll get
it this time josh you go here we go game
spot
uh lowercase s node.com also wasn't our
game of the year
yeah
see if you can see the pc game's
reader's choice uh it was our reader's
game spot again stop where game spotted
where's next to financial they
intercapped at this time oh they did it
up there but still not the game of the
year no but you know you know what they
probably did is it was did it win one of
our platform games no oh jesus is one
our people's choice
game of the year which isn't even part
of our game of the year awards come on
exciting we do it afterwards but
according to that we gave a game of the
year twice that's almost as good as that
review for the tom hardy movie where
it's all four stars except for the
guardian but they put the two stars in
between the characters faces yeah so in
the grid of four stars it looked like a
four star it was genius so we love
dragon age inquisition here it was
actually nominated i think on every
single
award dude it was a really hard way to
go it was a really hard debate between
that and mordor yeah it was down to the
two of them yeah and then mordor ended
up pipping it uh yeah but we just
thought because josh was like yeah
josh's problem was that they put
gamespot after 3d hue goes
and the russian side he was like they
did ign and then these two and then us
and then i'm like i don't think at one
game of the year either so there you go
anyway dragon age acquisition i guess we
kind of did its
marketing for it anyway uh but just for
clarification not our game of the year
twice over no no uh gentlemen it's
gentlemen it's been an interesting a
couple of weeks for konami they put out
two games they put a metal gear solid
the phantom pain 10 out of 10 on
gamespot.com but at pre-evolution soccer
2016 910 on gamespot.com yes i'm playing
it over the weekend enjoying it quite a
lot still prefer fifa but it's really
really good um but obviously there was a
report came out last week saying that
sort of what we'd all feared was that
konami uh were pulling out of aaa
development apart from pro evolution
which is a sort of a easy bank it makes
a lot of money for them and specifically
in japan and europe mainland europe a
lot of um peter
i guess first of all
there's since been another report saying
that this isn't the case but that's from
like a customer service rep or something
somebody putting a support ticket to
konami's customer support line saying
are you guys no longer making triple-a
console games and
the response was of course we are we're
still making castlevania metal gear like
pez like
i would not put much credence behind
this support ticket response because one
that's that's no sort of official answer
to that person may not even be at the
company like they could just be a hired
third party who like has like a blanket
slate of things to say and is just like
uh yeah
yeah so yeah the line they said was i
can promise you that we're definitely
not leaving metal gear behind or
anything like that i know some blogs
were claiming that online this morning
but i'm not really sure where they'd be
getting that information from like i
don't know two years of looking at
konami um we're definitely still working
on console games and franchises such as
metal gear not mega solid we're gonna
bring back the msx games um silent hill
castlevania pez and all the rest okay so
that's four they named and all the rest
let's assume that's three now that's
silent scope and
bomberman act zero and dance dance
revolution and you have goemon in there
and you have other hudson properties
whatever anyway the point is is that
where the hell are they making these
games yeah because they have like two
different studios now and they they were
working with uh they had a third party
that they're i can't remember the name
right now they're working on the
castlevania games they've shut down
they're no longer doing that uh david
cox the guy who was a head of
castlevania left the person who's in
charge of silent hill and metal gear is
bound to leave any day now yeah i mean
who is making these games where are they
getting made and why the hell should we
believe that they're being made for
consoles there's no evidence to support
it and if there's not an official
statement like these are the games these
are where they're being made these are
the consoles like
we can only really logically assume that
these are not happening so there was a
quote um i can't remember who exactly it
was somebody tied to konami one of the
executives um earlier this week as well
that was basically them saying oh no
we're going to use these properties but
we're not going to use them in the
traditional way we're going to have
mobile games for them we're going to go
in like in different directions right
towards where especially the japanese
market is focused at the moment yeah and
he basically said this is our main
platform now i mean he said if it makes
sense down the road we'll continue
making games for consoles but that
doesn't mean anything isn't that like
incredibly wearing mic because konami
have it's it would be one thing if they
stopped making games but the idea that
they're going to be sort of almost like
disney not releasing dvds like they've
got this massive chest of ips that
people love but they're going to be
presumably releasing mobile games maybe
pachinko machines about them but not
actual real console games yeah because
just last year i remember thinking wow
konami's got a bunch a lot of good stuff
coming up they just you know pt had come
out and then they said oh this is
actually going to be silent hills and
then you're really excited about that
and then you know they're bringing on
guillermo del guillermo del toro and
they're going to have uh norman reedus
if that matters too much but
every time i kept thinking to myself
it's going to be awesome like the
phantom pain is coming out next year
ground zeroes was great it would just it
turned out that's not gonna happen you
know there was a silent hills
controversy and then all the kojima
stuff started happening and you kind of
realize
a lot of these were just maybe not
initially false promises but they
developed into that and then it kind of
just became i feel like they were just
kind of in a condescending way saying
yeah we're still having all this coming
out but i just didn't see any evidence
to support that which sucks like isn't
that weird because it is kind of a hard
swing peter when you think about what
mike was saying last year like there was
a lot of stuff happening there were new
franchises being announced seems to kind
of like
in six months they decided oh no
actually we're going to completely pull
out of console development entirely well
they have completely shifted the the
people at the head at the head of the
company and that sort of came um you
know like
i love metal gear solid five i respect a
lot of what hideo kojima does
i i think the sentiment online is is
probably accurate when people say that
he
you know
spent so much time and money making this
game that he probably doomed the chance
for konami to
make console games in the future you
know specifically when you're trying to
compete with something like this like
how are they going to match this game
yeah like what game can they release
that will stand up to this this game had
astronomical budget like huge ideas it
was in development for five or six years
which is not unusual these days the
sequel to a long-standing beloved
franchise right so it had that packed
into it and so when you look at mobile
development right they can spend
three you know just hypothetically three
months making a game it catches on in
japan because that is where the biggest
fan base is people are used to spending
money on micro transactions they're
gonna make money hand over fist why
would they want to support a team that
is so large that with a project that's
so ambitious that it could fall apart so
you know i think it it makes sense for
konami to do this and while i will miss
the presence of these series like on
shelves and hearing news online and
stuff i don't think jim is going to stop
making games so if you're a fan of his
work you're going to be able to look
forward to stuff
how can you how can you not keep going
but also
i think people need to wake up and stop
demanding that we get another metal gear
or another castlevania i think it's it's
up to creative people that if they want
to support these franchises or at least
the ideas and themes they represent to
take the source material use it as
inspiration build something new from it
and move on like we can't keep living in
the past i mean i
love old games i love old series like
they're really important to me but at
the same time we need new things and
just because they don't carry the same
title doesn't mean a new game can't you
know reflect the things that are
wonderful about
games like this from konami yeah look at
what ega's doing with bloodstain it's
very much going to be a spiritual
predecessor to castlevania for all
intents and purposes it sounds like it's
a castlevania game without the name
absolutely same thing with it yeah
although the quality of that will
innovate
yeah yeah so it's just it's it's
interesting to see you know ego went to
kickstart you know like not assuming
anything with kojima but what's to stop
him from doing the same thing yeah i
mean and i don't necessarily want those
creators to do what they have always
done
i actually
i i'm glad to get that game from iga now
but i'd be interested to see what he
does next and the same with inafune like
i think recoil is a really good example
of him i mean it's still taking the
mechanic of
you know augmentations you know like
opening up new doors and abilities and
that's great but it's still a very new
universe and it's a new style of game
play i want to see hideo kojima do
something different that was i think the
promise
of silent hills was that it was a
totally like turn
uh
turn of direction for him and that's
wonderful so i would like to see new
talent tackle new series mercury steam
is the name of the company they did
really well by castlevania i think it
wasn't the old games we loved but it was
a really interesting take that
emphasized things about those games that
hadn't been utilized before like the
world the music like these things were
presented so well you could say the same
thing about revengeance as well
absolutely i love your vengeance and
people you know get upset because oh
well it's not a real metal gear game but
it's like okay but it's still a
wonderful game like you're looking at it
through a lens that isn't necessarily
you know the same for everybody it's
very subjective um so yeah i would like
to see these talents do new things and
maybe creators spin off stuff that we
love from the past last question on this
um i remember a couple of years ago when
the success of mobile games was really
kicking off like angry birds was making
money hand over fist before a lot of
free to play stuff came into the market
um but a lot of gamers especially online
especially on like message boards and
stuff talking about how oh mobile games
are going to be
death nail for consoles or like this is
a dangerous thing or like being
aggressive towards mobile gaming what
we're having here though is we have a
company like konami who is like an old
name within video games who is
essentially leaving console directions
because of the card on the stick that
mobile games is is that something we
should be worried about looking forward
well i think it's going to be there's
going to be a lull like we're going to
hit a valley where we see the big name
companies
not investing as much in console games
but
there is a demand for big console games
that's not necessarily going away
in the united states and in europe and
in japan things are changing but
in a lot of the western gaming markets
that's still up and it's on the rise so
i think even if it's not konami we're
going to see other companies do it but
we still have plenty of old companies
making great games there's a lot of them
happen to be japanese at least that come
to mind like capcom and square enix
those guys are still doing some really
impressive work in some areas so i think
console gaming will be fine mobile
gaming will have an impact on it
but it's not going to be i don't think a
death knell for console gaming or pc
gaming
hope not thanks so much gentlemen for
coming on talking about that uh let us
know what you think about the
sad demise of konami at least in the
console space are you sad will you be
happy for kojima to do something new let
us know in the comments below all right
we've got one more section coming up in
a section uh in a second but first of
all uh guild wars 2 uh this is a game we
gave a 9 out of 10 to back in 2013
i think it's three years old now uh the
expansion pack though first expansion
pack uh heart of thorns um is coming out
uh later this month uh october 23rd
actually uh super soon uh sorry in about
a month from now uh we've got an
exclusive trailer to show off right now
it's got a bunch of information about
nolan north troy baker jennifer hale and
all the voice actors
on the game uh this is a pretty cool
looking trailer so let's check it out
it's not often that he get a chance to
stay with the character for as long as
we have with these characters we started
in 2009
so we're going almost six years that
we've been working on this for one game
the stories became more important so
therefore they needed actors to come in
and actually
bring life to those characters that
they've worked so hard to create
become part of me and endure
or fall forever into oblivion
i love the sylvari naivete that has
evolved over the course of the games
i've lived with this character for a
long time now
and i love what she stands for but
humanity's resolve will never waver we
have withstood every challenge thrown at
us because unity is our strength i think
the goal of any story is especially when
it's a long running thing is for to
evolve and for it to change or to grow
you shouldn't see the same person all
the way throughout especially over six
years you need to see a different side
of them but around that circumstances
always change characters and conflict
reveals character so as we've seen
different conflicts happen you're going
to see different characters
the thing that appeals to me about air
is uh she has had a complicated life
which makes her a complex character
while she is very strong and very
capable and very mighty
as an actress the part that i'm most
attached to are the poignant moments
with her there's nothing better inside
of the gaming community than speculation
and people that can be vehement and
passionate about their reasons and cite
examples of why they're right and you're
wrong so there's this long running much
debated thing as far as when logan
decided to leave did he do it of his own
accord or was it something that jenna
did to him and there's people on both
sides of the fence that you know have
strong cases
for either side and i could speculate i
could i could tell you what i think but
it's my secret i think what logan did
was a combination of the two i think
queen jenner you know had a little bit
of a hand but logan did as well i think
it was both of them that's what i'm
going to say
there's so much to me that's revealed
about character and the impact of the
story through the people that play it
because they get to
take away different things it's been
amazing to be here
from beginning
all the way up to the
huge announcement in january and to be
there with all the fans it was this
community is incredible it's like a
level above it's it's amazing it's a
wonderful community and i'm just really
excited for launch i can't wait to see
everybody's experience of this thing
because it's gorgeous what's what you
guys are putting together is just
stunning
he's a good boy
hey what's up
destiny the taken king it's out we
talked about it a bit last week but we
couldn't talk about all of it because
the raid hadn't been unlocked but it has
now right mike mccarty yeah you played
it yeah how was your weekend a lot of
destiny yeah it was good though the raid
especially is really a highlight of the
expansion
it's definitely the longest the boss at
the end who a lot of people might know
who it is but i don't know if that would
be a spoiler to say don't say it then i
won't um it's the guy even breaking bad
yeah oh mike yeah yeah i'm just kidding
keep going it's not like but yeah no the
the raid's really great there are these
you know the interspersed mini bosses
and when i say many i use that term
flexibly because they're pretty i think
one has something like 16 million health
or something oh wow which is just as
much as it sounds but is it as is it as
difficult as when like you played other
raids in destiny first time yes uh it's
i'd say more so there's a lot of first
person platforming which i didn't like
which i guess if you pull out your heavy
sword it wouldn't be first person so i
have to try that see if that works um
but anyway it's
i don't know it starts really it starts
cool you're in near the court of oryx
where people have been playing it they
know it's like that public area where
you're fighting boss waves which is one
of the highlights expansions as well but
this i think is eric tay's footage i
really hope we see him fall off because
he fell off
but at the time he was making fun of me
for something i had just done and then
he fell off and he's listening right now
there's a lot of platforming stuff i saw
andy playing a part where the
the um the
like
floors like appear in front of you as
you're like trying to get around yeah
you use your ghost and then it
highlights it's kind of like that uh
leap of faith and the indian last
crusade instead of salt you have yeah a
cup of a carpenter
great destiny
so you've played the raid uh obviously
we talked last week sort of before the
reviews out so you've reviewed the kick
now what score to get eight eight out of
ten tell us what's good about it i got a
bunch of questions here from uh gamespot
uh viewers uh but first of all what is
your take on the taking game sure so i
liked it a lot as someone who
played a lot of destiny year one or
destiny vanilla you might say with the
two expansions uh house of wolves and
dark below
i
played a lot of it but i wasn't always
having fun because a lot of the late
game stuff is repetitive and the story
itself didn't have much weight didn't
lend much context to what i was doing
which
i
i lend a lot of credence to that a lot
of games i think if they can kind of
create this narrative and structure it
the campaign in a way that i feel
momentum carrying me forward i think
that lends a lot to the
missions themselves
and also you know a lot of the bosses
were bullet sponges and all you were
doing was shooting going back into cover
reloading pulling out your rocket
launcher shooting going back reloading
yeah never that's why i found so much of
the action so tedious i felt like i was
doing the same thing felt empty kind of
it it was really promising to see these
gorgeous worlds before the game came out
and everything you're like oh we can go
to mars after it's been settled for a
while we go to earth after it's been
destroyed by this well not the trade the
traveler comes and then the darkness
follows it and destroys earth and
everything the solar system in general
and it'll be cool to do all that but the
worlds weren't as fun to explore as i
was hoping but with the taken king the
dreadnought it's a ship in the rings of
saturn that an intro cutscene shows it
you know coming up against the awoken
fighting it that's the race of um kind
of alien human hybrid and it's like more
interesting area more stuff to do like
in what way is it more entertaining
there are more things to just find if
you're exploring there's a lot of chess
there are these um
chests that says you need these specific
keys to get and you don't know how to do
it this is the court of oryx i just
mentioned before it's probably one of
the
more fun things to do in the expansion
you put in these runes and we had up to
seven people at once like fighting these
bosses and there's tier one tier two
tier three obviously higher tier the
harder they are um here's another part
that's just coming so yeah there's a bit
of solid last crusade kind of stuff but
yeah it's just overall it's a more
it's a little it feels
i think it's like on par with the size
of earth and everything um this is of
actual earth
yeah
it seems like the sort of destiny they
should have launched with where it's
more fleshed out there's more cutscenes
it's more like sort of rounded instead
of it being like a bunch of for me it
seemed like a bunch of like templated um
combat instances that were sort of
ramshackled together in various
different ways a lot of repetition and
stuff like yeah whereas from your review
yeah it seems like there's a lot more uh
variety a lot more like depth each sure
yeah there's eight strikes if you're
playing on playstation there's one extra
but the bosses themselves are awesome in
my opinion i think that
contrary to what i was saying before
they still take a lot of damage but in
between that you're doing more um one of
my favorites was called the restorative
mind and it's this vex
enemy and you're he's invulnerable for a
while right here you can see it and um
you essentially have to coordinate with
your teammates to get this relic and
then bring it over to
another uh
kind of
entry point so he will lower shields and
go to fix it now by the time you start
blowing up but he's also got this force
field it's kind of the arena itself like
a doughnut shape so he's rotating this
force field kind of dictating where you
go so you could think you're behind
cover then all of a sudden you just feel
something pushing you to where you're
shooting and it sucks but at the same
time you're like i could have avoided
that if i thought ahead and then he's
spawning these enemies the whole time
and the entire time you're kind of just
yelling back and forth to each other
like oh i'll cloak you you go grab it
and then you distract him run over here
that's cool like combat variety within
that boss fight instead of just picking
a spot each person to pop from behind
cover and then go reload then fill that
sponge full of bullets i got a bunch of
questions from folks i'm going to get
through them pretty quick and nick
buster asks as a player fresh off the
boat does the old content from vanilla
destiny and the first two dlcs become
redundant
yeah so as the expansion as an expansion
on its own taken king's great
transformed a lot of what i didn't like
about destiny but you will if you're
starting from level one say and you're
going up to get the taken king you do
have a spark of light it's this item you
get from postmaster that you can
just use pop and you'll instantly beat
the level 25 ready for the king and with
a little bit better gear to be prepared
for that so i did that with one of my
characters see how it went and it was
that was fine but playing from level one
just i was curious how the quest log
would fit into it now that they redid
all the user interface stuff
you do still have to go through that old
stuff i mean there's it's a better
organization the quest log the is the xp
faster perhaps like is the level
progression faster though um it's no
it's still the same speed but once you
hit 20 it doesn't stop obviously right
40 now which that was refreshing because
you know you get to probably like
venus which is
pretty later on in the story and you
might not hit 20 by the end of the story
i think you could but
you it won't be as repetitive once you
hit that so it's it's still it's
definitely worth getting back into
destiny now i think if you were either
hesitating or if you kind of were put
off by it for a while which i was as
well so it's a good time to get back
into it because it not only has more con
end game content to
supplement you know the grind later on
which it doesn't become a ground until
like 15 hours in the taken king but
it does help a little bit with the
earlier game stuff which i didn't love
cool bit of a slog though if you're
starting off like directly from the
start sure okay cool uh martin shepard
asks feeling on the elimination of the
player's base sorry the player base that
didn't buy all the dlc uh they can't do
a lot of things they could do before
so this was a big reddit thread i
remember last week there's a bunch of
content that they were like folks who
haven't bought the taken king
had access to which they're kind of
being frozen out of and now what do you
think of all that aspect of it yeah
because
so from what i understand so when the
house of wolves came out you were there
were these uh public events instances
where you would hunt these uh these wolf
captains and that would be a big part of
playing into the quest of the house of
wolves and then that got wiped later
that pretty much um
just became obsolete because the taken
king was coming out right and also a lot
of the strikes which are pretty
essential like the strike playlist the
longer you stay in it the better chance
at good gear you have so
these strikes themselves are taken king
strikes though so i'm not sure if bungie
we have reached out to ask if they're
gonna
try to rectify that in the future if you
don't buy the taken king because
the pricing model for is still confusing
to me you can get all them for 60 now if
you haven't bought any of them is that
true but tanking on its own is 40.
yeah they've definitely like
if you now want to buy everything it's
not like wow where you need to basically
buy everything they have subsidized
heavily for new people yeah so i hope
that's not the case i hope they do
something to rectify that because then
that the case would be if you're trying
to
do all these strikes for better gear
which they're pretty essential then you
won't be able to unless you have taken
king so i'm hoping that they'll
introduce
a way for the older players because you
could still do those specific strikes
from vanilla destiny but that won't be
the strike playlist so you won't have as
good a chance at better gear because you
won't get that streak going so let's
strike straight by that distress the
strike straight yeah strike streak great
contribution peter
so i'm here we'll get to you in a second
oh
megan maestro asks uh
this b-boy actually uh how close to the
mmo floor plan should bungee adhere to
will expansions like this be enough for
10 years
is it starting to feel like it's
straining a little bit or does it uh
well like would you be happy getting a
taken king or two taking kings every
year and spending 40 bucks on them all
taken king seems like it was doing more
to revamp destiny as a platform which
you know that's what bungie originally
set out to do in addition to making
games they just wanted to do something
that they could update yeah throughout
the years with paid dlc yeah 10 years
seems like it would be a stretch i know
that's
is that like something they've well that
destiny 2 is probably what they're going
to come out with yeah um i think it will
be a strainer for a while i think taken
king is promising because it's not it
seems fresh to me it's the first
expansion i really liked i played dark
blue and house evolved just out of
obligation because not out of obligation
i wanted to play them because you know
you could get better stuff and it was
just i was interested to see how destiny
was morphing between expansions yes but
taken king was definitely the most
drastic
i don't think they're gonna do something
as drastic with each one um maybe there
will be a destiny 3.0 that they'll you
know kind of shape depending on feedback
from year two now that the patch is out
and taken king
um i don't see it being substantial
enough to last 10 years but let me ask
the next question then uh coffee jesus
great name asks where do you think
destiny goes from here more planets and
raids or another curveball entirely like
as a destiny fan like looking towards
like they have this deal with activision
that's going to go for at least another
eight years of them creating this
franchise uh whether they have like a
new boxed game where it all hits reset
again or whether they keep adding new
packs to destiny what is it do you want
destiny to be in like
a year 18 months two years
uh yeah like i don't see them doing
another major update for
at least another year i know like the
best part about taking king was all
based on feedback so i think we'd have
to wait and see from my perspective i
would very much
yeah like them to keep it'd be great to
keep going back to explore planets it's
just a bummer you have to pay
every single time you want to see that
but i mean the game is substantial on
its own now i know mercury is in the pvp
maps and we all kind of have suspicions
that might be the next thing they work
on mercury is rising yep can you see
yourself playing this game in six months
if there is another piece of dlc because
the one thing and it's if there isn't
because they're like with their will
obviously but like the one like massive
criticism i have this game is that i
think it's been completely purposefully
designed so that you have to keep your
eye on dlc because the amount of content
that's there just isn't good enough it's
not entertaining enough and like people
are getting bored so they're like oh we
have to make an rpc dlc and people will
pay for it because they've invested all
this time so like if they hadn't
released another 40 dlc let's say like
april of next year would you keep
playing destiny
is it a game that's based entirely on
these massive updates that they're
charging for yeah i think so very much
uh the thing separating like just not to
put too much weight on the score but
like i debated like what score to give
it and the thing that kept it from being
higher than an eight was
after about 15 16 hours once you get
into the grind it's which i don't mind
grinding if i feel like it's worth it
but like you said it was kind of boring
you were doing you were taking out these
the same walker tanks that you've been
shooting at since the first strike of
destiny you're it's nothing substantial
enough there's no it's not a foundation
for this
there's a foundation for growth in in
terms of expansion but not for just
anything emergent that comes out of it
from enjoying it on its own if they want
to release expansion i can't see myself
playing it in six months consistently
like i am now it's interesting you know
destiny the destiny we have now is
different to what it was obviously a
year ago we originally reviewed it six
out of ten like who knows in 12 months
time it might they might add so much
incredible interesting content that it
does have that sort of super longevity
without having the supplemental packs
last question on this peter as somebody
who enjoys lots of games online shooters
first person shooters what is your take
on destiny you don't play it right much
at all i've started to play it casually
and uh to be fair i don't play a lot of
multiplayer shooters i like first person
shooters and third person shooters if
it's the right game the right mix of
themes in action whatever anyway that
said uh destiny reminds me a lot of
fantasy star online which is a game that
i loved that was very short on content
and it was all about the hunt for loot
and i see everyone around the office
playing and that is sort of the primary
driving force
and and i and i can appreciate that
right because it's that sort of like
reward mentality that
makes you feel good and there's nothing
wrong with it so i'm playing it casually
to sort of get into it before i
completely miss the boat um and because
it reminds me of a game i used to love
uh and because sega will not release
fantasy star online two in north america
i'm forced to play destiny but uh you
know i think the art direction is
wonderful i do like the the shooting
like the action feels good um and i you
know i sort of hit even early on some
boredom with the original version um so
i'm
i'm gonna go through the grind and earn
my levels and not use the the light
spark but i'm looking forward to
actually getting into the taken king
stuff because everyone sounds really
positive yeah about it um you know to an
extent so uh
given all my other curiosities like yeah
i'm curious to see where the series go
it's cool and i'm happy for the destiny
fans as well they seem to have gotten
the expansion back that they have earned
and deserve after so much time playing
as well uh but yeah let us know in the
comments what you think destiny the
technique have you been playing since
day one if you picked up the taken king
uh what do you think about it let us
know in the comments below and that's
the show folks how's the show that's the
show peter brown mike maherty thank you
so much for coming on uh what are you
doing for the rest of your week peter
what's going on after our samurai 2
today um i might try to play undertale
undertale undertale i don't know
undertale uh just came out a couple days
ago a lot of people are chatting about
it because it's sort of an old-school
style rpg where
things it's not like
all the tropes and cliches we know and
love like it's it's very different and
that makes it interesting like you go to
a town normally in the past it'd be like
you need to go talk to the mayor austin
walker tweeted out this photo last night
this town has no mayor like you talked
to a guy they're like yeah there's no
one running this town like it's just
things like that it flips stuff on its
head and it's getting a lot of praise so
i'm going to play that and maybe even
have a review for next week sweet mike
what are you doing that you can talk
about that's not under embargo
bouncing back and forth between the
rainbow six siege beta oh yeah and
playing civilization beyond earth to get
ready for the rising tide expansion
which is early october yes and faraxicon
is on the week after next
i think is that right josh
next week between now and the expansion
10 days away yes we'll have some xcom 2
stuff maybe there we'll have some sid
meier's stuff we'll have to see uh we're
going to have b exclusively streaming
that on gamespot.com so if you're a big
fan of sid meier and all his cronies
jake solomon at al and make sure you
tune back to gamespot uh that sounds
cool right i've got that tony hawk
episode of the point going up this week
i want to do game stop plays about
unreal tournaments pre-alpha though
because it's so good
and playing it makes me feel like i'm so
old because it's basically the same one
i was like playing facing worlds in
instagram and going oh my god this looks
amazing and then after an hour being
like yeah but it's it's facing worlds it
ends the gib i could be playing the 99
version of this and it'll be almost the
exact same i heard you kind of like
screaming and laughing from your desk
friday and i assumed you were playing i
don't know metal gear against cars you
come over and you're playing yeah unreal
tournament yeah because that's the
situation in which i feel like the
[ __ ] for being so critical of destiny
because i'm literally playing an hd
remake of a game that came out 15 years
ago 16 years ago and like losing my mind
in the office but i don't know different
jokes are different folks we can't have
what we love uh yeah so maybe against
what plays of that later in the week we
shall see thank you so much to everyone
for watching of course every week for
sending in your questions for ask the
reviewer for chatting and for putting in
the comments really appreciate it thanks
everyone in the back for uh producing
today's show josh shaw eric tay dan
mchork and the folks would be very happy
to get mary kish back next week there's
been a small team running this show we
need her back come back from tokyo mary
uh thanks so much to everyone for
watching we'll be back next week uh
right here on the lobby 2pm pacific same
time but if you're bored between then
and now make sure you go to gamespot.com
for all the latest reviews news and
previews on video games we'll see you
next week folks bye-bye
you